fournisse des solutions.
Essayons de comprendre quel serait le rôle du monde des affaires.
Vous pensez sûrement que je vais parler de la philanthropie d'entreprise
ou la responsabilité sociale des entreprises (RSE).
Le RSE est la norme actuelle,
et elle est très utile.
Elle ouvre la voie à une générosité de l'entreprise
et cette générosité est importante pour beaucoup d'employés
et leurs clients.
Mais vous savez quoi ?
Ce n'est pas suffisant, pas assez fort, pas assez durable,
pour trouver des solutions aux grands problèmes du monde d'aujourd'hui,
car elle a un coût croissant.
Même lorsque les affaires fleurissent,
le RSE n'est pas faite pour s'agrandir.
Et bien sûr, quand les affaires vont mal,
c'est l'un des premiers programmes à être supprimés.
Donc non, la RSE,
la Responsabilité Sociale des Entreprises,
n'est pas la réponse.
Mais l'IST, l'Impact Sociétal Total, l'est.
L'IST est le cumul de toutes les manières
dont les entreprises affectent la société
en faisant ce qui compte vraiment :
penser à leurs chaînes d'approvisionnement,
travailler sur le design de leurs produits et les processus de fabrication
et leur distribution.
Le vrai travail des entreprises,
quand il est fait de façon innovante,
peut créer des avantages commerciaux pour leur activité principale
et résoudre les problèmes significatifs du monde d'aujourd'hui.
À quoi ressemble l'impact sociétal ?
Se concentrer sur cet impact
permettrait d'intégrer des considérations environnementales et sociales.
Et vous savez quoi ? Ce n'est pas totalement nouveau.
On y pense depuis longtemps.
Mais les entreprises continuent de ne penser presque qu'exclusivement
qu'à ce qu'on appelle le RTA :
le rendement total pour les actionnaires.
Mais l'IST, l'impact sociétal total,
doit être considéré de la même façon que le rendement total
comme un important et solide moteur de stratégie d'entreprise
et de prise de décisions collective.
Nous avons les données nécessaires pour vous le démontrer.
Certaines entreprises ont déjà mis en place ce concept.
Elles commencent à l'appliquer.
Laissez-moi vous parler de Mars.
Mars est la sixième plus grande entreprise privée des États-Unis.
Si vous êtes comme moi,
ils fabriquent des produits importants,
comme le café ou le chocolat.
Il n'est donc pas surprenant
que l'un de leurs ingrédients phares soit le cacao.
Certains de leur concurrents sont inquiets par rapport
à l'accessibilité et à la durabilité de leur approvisionnement en cacao.
Mais pas Mars.
Mars est assurée de son approvisionnement en cacao sur la durée.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils sont partenaires avec des ONG du monde entier
qui travaillent avec de petits fermiers actionnaires.
Et ces ONG certifiées
aident les fermiers à améliorer le rendement de leurs récoltes,
s'assurent qu'ils aient un salaire juste et suffisant pour vivre.
Ils les aident à résoudre tout problème concernant les droits de l'Homme
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement,
et ils aident à minimiser les effets sur l'environnement,
comme la déforestation.
Mars est en passe de devenir un acheteur de cacao 100% certifié.
C'est donc un bon programme pour les communautés fermières,
c'est un bon programme pour l'environnement,
et un bon programme pour Mars,
qui a résolu un problème significatif dans sa chaîne d'approvisionnement.
Mais parlons maintenant des données,
car c'est en réalité incroyable.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer les points importants des données dont on va parler.
Quand les analystes et les services de finance observent les entreprises,
ils pensent à toutes les différentes statistiques.
Je vais parler des deux plus importantes.
Je vais parler de la valeur totale de l'entreprise,
son estimation,
et je vais parler de ses marges.
C'est la différence entre les revenus
et les coûts.
Dans notre étude,
on a observé des compagnies pétrolières.
Celles qui ont de meilleures performances au niveau de l'IST,
l'Impact Sociétal Total,
comptent une majoration de 19% de leur évaluation.
19%, quand elles s'en sortent vraiment bien
dans la minimisation de l'impact de leur entreprise
sur l'environnement et l'eau,
et quand elles mettent en place de sérieux programmes de santé et de sécurité.
Et si elles ajoutent de solides programmes de formation pour leurs employés,
elles améliorent leurs marges de 3,4 % de points.
Mais qu'en est-il des autres secteurs ?
Les compagnies biopharmaceutiques sont les plus performantes en termes d'IST,
avec une surévaluation de 12%.
Et si elles améliorent l'accessibilité aux médicaments,
en rendant leur accès possible aux personnes qui en ont besoin,
elles voient leurs marges brutes augmenter de 6,7 % de points.
Pour les banques de détail, qui ont le meilleur IST,
elles totalisent une amélioration de 3 % de points.
Et pour celles qui proposent une inclusion financière,
l'accès aux produits financiers pour ceux qui en ont besoin,
elles voient leur marge nette augmenter de 0,5%.
Ces chiffres peuvent paraître dérisoires pour des banques
mais dans des secteurs où la concurrence est élevée,
la moindre variation de marge a son importance.
Qu'en est-il des sociétés de biens de consommation
qui produisent ce que nous adorons, comme le café ou le chocolat ?
Les entreprises qui ont l'impact sociétal total le plus performant
voient une amélioration de 11%.
Et s'ils travaillent intelligemment avec leur chaîne d'approvisionnement,
en s'approvisionnant de manière responsable et solidaire,
elles totalisent une augmentation de 4,8% sur leurs marges brutes.
Ces chiffres sont significatifs.
Nous savons depuis longtemps que les fondamentaux en finance,
les taux de croissance et les risques financiers
sont des facteurs clés dans l'évaluation d'une entreprise.
Mais cette analyse montre que les facteurs sociaux et environnementaux,
les mesures sur l'impact sociétal total,
sont également liés à l'évaluation et aux marges.
Waouh !
Sauf imprévu, l'analyse est correcte.
Sauf imprévu,
les entreprises qui ont de bons résultats en matière d'environnement et de social
augmentent leurs marges et augmentent leurs évaluations.
Maintenant, je comprends bien que les entreprises
subissent de grosses pressions par rapport à leurs gains à court terme.
Mais heureusement,
les investisseurs qui exercent cette pression
commencent de plus en plus à penser au long terme
et à intégrer l'IST dans cette réflexion.
Au cours de nos échanges et sondages auprès des investisseurs,
75% déclarent s'attendre à ce que leur chiffre d'affaire augmente
et que l'efficacité de leur exploitation s'améliore
pour les entreprises qui gardent comme objectif l'IST.
Et ils commencent déjà à l'intégrer
dans leurs comportements d'investissement.
L'année dernière,
23 000 milliards d'actifs globaux
concernaient l'investissement socialement responsable.
Cela représente 5 milliards de plus que les deux dernières années
et un quart des actifs mondiaux.
Je sais que cela en fait grimacer certains.
Au fil de mes années d'expérience en conseil stratégique
avec des entreprises, des ONG et des gouvernements du monde entier,
je m'aperçois que beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
sont hésitants quand il s'agit d'évoquer ou même de penser
aux avantages commerciaux des bonnes actions.
Ils s'imaginent parfois que ça va remettre en cause
la valeur des avantages qu'ils génèrent pour la société.
Ou qu'ils seront perçus comme des mercenaires ou des êtres sans cœur.
Mais nous nous devons vraiment de penser différemment.
Nous devons penser différemment,
car la seule façon de progresser de manière considérable,
dans la gestion des problèmes d'aujourd'hui,
repose sur les entreprises qui vont fournir ces solutions.
Le but des entreprises est de répondre aux besoins des clients
et de le faire de manière rentable.
Elles doivent le faire pour survivre.
Donc la meilleure manière pour assurer les entreprises de leur croissance,
de leur longévité,
c'est de faire face aux plus grands défis de notre société
et de le faire de manière rentable.
Et quand elles le font de manière innovante,
de manière éthique, responsable, remarquable,
elles doivent en être fières.
Et si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincu,
prenons d'autres exemples.
Imaginez une entreprise technologique,
vous essayez de faire grandir votre plateforme
et d'augmenter votre nombre de clients.
Comme Airbnb.
Airbnb possède une gamme d'activités à l'impact sociétal total.
Ils en font le cœur de leurs affaires.
Avec une seule initiative,
ils aident leur communauté
à loger gratuitement les personnes dans le besoin :
des rescapés et des personnels de secours.
Dans un autre de leurs efforts,
ils aident et travaillent avec les ONG
pour s'assurer que les gens puissent loger gratuitement des réfugiés.
Ce que j'aime dans ce programme,
c'est que les gens n'auraient pas compris
comment montrer leur générosité
et accueillir chez eux les gens dans le besoin,
aussi rapidement, et de manière aussi efficace,
sans l'aide innovante d'Airbnb.
Mais en même temps,
c'est le cœur de leur stratégie d'entreprise
et de leur croissance.
Car leur croissance est basée sur le nombre d'hôtes et de clients
utilisant leur plateforme.
Mais s'ils avaient pensé uniquement
au retour sur investissement,
je ne pense pas qu'ils auraient eu le même programme de croissance.
Car ils n'ont pas de frais de service.
Donc c'est extraordinaire
qu'ils aient concilié l'apport de leurs services
à une société dans le besoin
et cette façon d'améliorer leur croissance en même temps.
Mais si on veut trouver une nouvelle branche de clients ?
Regardons l'Afrique du Sud
et parlons de Standard Bank.
En Afrique du Sud,
le gouvernement a une loi
stipulant que chaque banque doit donner 0,2% de ses bénéfices
aux petits et moyens commerces tenus par des gens de couleur.
Beaucoup de banques donnent ces 0,2% aux entrepreneurs,
mais Standard Bank est sorti des sentiers battus.
Ils ont pris ce capital en considération
et l'ont investi dans une fiduciaire indépendante,
et ils ont utilisé cette fiduciaire pour financer des prêts
à ces entrepreneurs de couleur.
C'est une très bonne rentabilisation.
Ils peuvent soutenir beaucoup plus d'entrepreneurs,
et comme leur succès est entremêlé à celui des entrepreneurs,
ils peuvent aussi utiliser ce capital pour leur fournir une aide technique.
Plus d'entrepreneurs soutenus
et plus de personnes qui sortent de la pauvreté.
Et ça marche pour Standard Bank.
Tellement, que ce programme est sur le point de s'étendre
à de nouveaux domaines dans leur portefeuille d'actions.
Je ne dis pas qu'on n'a pas tenté de résoudre les problèmes du monde
depuis un certain temps.
Nous avons tenté, mais ils sont toujours là.
Nous avons progressé,
mais pas suffisamment,
trop lentement,
et pas assez au niveau universel.
Nous devons changer notre façon de penser.
Nous avons besoin que les affaires,
entreprises comme actionnaires,
créent des stratégies d'entreprise créatives, innovantes
et qu'elles aient le capital pour résoudre les plus gros problèmes de notre monde.
Et quand elles feront ça, de manière innovante,
évaluant toutes les stratégies possibles et imaginables,
investissant leur capital au maximum,
créant les rémunérations totales des actionnaires
tout en gardant en tête l'impact sociétal total,
nous savons que nous résoudrons ces problèmes,
de façon rentable et généreuse.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)